what's up guys welcome back it's your
girl jess and um we are going to be
reacting today
to johnny depp and amber
i don't know her last name to amber
heard amber heard um some of the best
things that have happened in their
the trial so have you heard anything
about their trial at all have you yes
okay okay what do you know about the
trial
that she pooped on the bed
so
basically
have you okay do you know anything about
the justice system
like with um how it discriminates
against men
i know that it leans more towards like a
woman like what she said like that's it
and if a man if it goes against a man is
like
so women get four times the sentence or
men get four times the
sentencing as women for the same crime
wow
yeah
and so it's kind of like we've seen this
in our culture where
men just have not been taken seriously
when it comes to allegations of like
abuse
and again when i when i see something
come to the forefront of a society like
coming to the public i feel like that is
indicative of what's been going on in
society as a whole so like for example
kanye not being able to see his kids
yeah i feel like that was indicative
like if a billionaire can't see his kids
what about the what about everyone else
so right now if johnny depp's getting
abused who else is who yeah who imagine
the average guy who doesn't have lawyers
time or money yeah and getting falsely
accused
that's hard and so she came out during
um the
during the metoo movement
and she wrote this article about how she
was an abusive relationship um
wow
yeah and everyone knew who he was
who like she's she was in a public
relationship with him everyone she
didn't say his name but everyone knew it
was about him
you're a famous person right right and
and so then he's not in pirates of the
caribbean anymore
i know i when's the last time i saw that
yeah and i'm like um
that movie's going to be trash and if
they get somebody to play his part
no it's not the same johnny depp
i haven't seen all of them but
he
he is one of the best characters in that
movie and that's the best that is the
best that is the only reason why i want
to
watch pius at the caribbean is because
of the way he
embodied jack sparrow oh it was genius
but now that he's not in it i'm about to
watch the new movie no but he basically
ruined his career based on one
accusation
that now we're finding out wasn't even
true
and how are we in a society that gives
that much power to one group
that we can we can just accuse someone
of something with no evidence and he
loses a career
now i wonder
if
i wonder if feminists are talking about
that about how
when it comes to the justice system that
women hold so much power when in some
situations it shouldn't be
no
they don't care it's only it's it's
like they don't want equality they want
equality when it benefits women
that is what feminists want every
everything you hear feminists fight for
is equality when it benefits women the
only thing that they talk about for men
is them being emotionally available
who does that benefit
oh wow
my envelope before we start the video
make sure you like comment
like the video comment down below if
there's anything else we should react to
and make sure you subscribe as well and
subscribe to jess's channel she's gonna
do some behind-the-scenes stuff we're
gonna do some vlogs
i'm going on holiday here soon so i'll
be doing some vloggy vlogs so make sure
you check it out oh and guys jess is
going home for three weeks so um there's
going to be a little gap in the content
but let us know what you want her to
react to when she gets back with us send
comments requests everything
okay let's are you ready though this is
a compilation
of the best moments of johnny depp being
a savage in court
i'm excited
[Music]
it's a pretty simple yes or no question
which is you'd love it
nothing simple in this case
before december that's correct smasher
pass oh
johnny johnny boy
johnny boy
i was mad
you ever wonder okay this is the thing
you didn't ask me on the last video oh
no i thank god
i was waiting for it
okay okay what question though
when i watch these videos it's johnny
depp and i hear all this [ __ ] that
happened i'm like johnny why don't you
pick me i know i'm not as hot as her but
i swear to god i wouldn't have pooped in
your bed
that's inhumane
pick me
i'm not a pikmi girl i promise i
absolutely am
i don't think it's an insult
really yeah i'm like a proud pick i want
to get picked i want to get married oh
people like that i'm still not a pikmi
girl
they call me a pick me on my channel all
the time and they think that's why i do
it i don't advocate for men's stuff
because of them i just advocate for what
i think is right but like
hell yeah i want to get picked i don't
want to die alone pick her yeah pick me
johnny okay
um the document that you signed as part
of your divorce proceedings correct
that is your signature on the right
correct
the look he gives him
he's like
yes like are you like why why are you
keep asking me this question like yes
and i know he this is the clip i saw he
keeps asking him i'd have been like your
honor
send this fool somewhere else because he
doesn't know what he's talking about
this is the document you've asked me
this how many times if you don't have
any other stuff to ask to make this case
viable
going with your day going with your day
this is the document you signed
right
[Music]
for the third time that is my signature
yes that was the document you signed in
august 2016.
correct is that the same one that i
signed three times before
i want to make clear that you signed
that for the summer paul bettany correct
again okay
so
she you you
i feel like her lawyers are like this
[ __ ] is crazy i don't i got nothing
that's why i could not be a lawyer
because if i
if i don't
believe that you're innocent
it's going to be hard for me to find
evidence to believe you're innocent or
i couldn't
i couldn't i feel
they're like you know what she kind of
deserves it let's
let's do a bad job
yo what if
come on guys
in the mornings too right
isn't happy hour anytime
carry cocaine in that box no but it
looks like it would fit some cocaine
[Music]
like
the lawyer is asking ridiculous
questions and
i applaud johnny for um just keeping his
composure because if that if that would
have been me on that stand and he would
have been like this
this is this the thing and asking these
ridiculous questions i've been like yo i
would have went off i wouldn't have
stayed calm but he
he's funny too
he's like um is that the document that i
signed three times ago all right he's
i'm trying to figure out who i lied to
these lawyers are getting millions of
dollars for this i know
that that's probably why her lawyers
don't care like i'm getting paid either
way i'm making bank off of this so i'm
gonna do whatever i want
like yes you are guilty you are not
innocent in this situation ma'am but
we're gonna
milk you for all you got
yo i mean
if you get up
sure that he would
stop talking so much
is that right
you did
did i read that correctly
you did okay did i read that right yes
she did did i read that right
you continue to read them
after you cut your finger off
that you are right after
i won't give you anything to argue with
me yet right after you sustain an injury
to your finger
that you
right after you sustain an injury to
your finger i like i was trying not to
say like she chopped your finger yes
just just say it just say it like it is
sir
sir you're stumbling would your client
do it what'd you do
say it
facts evidence he's like i'm not going
to give you anything that you can't
argue against
what are you gonna
there it shouldn't be an argument did
she chop your finger off yes yes or no
yes or no hmm
poured yourself a
a mega pint of red wine correct
who does it a mega pint
yeah fast forward in time a little bit
mr depp um yes i can feel it i have
other uses for your throat which do not
include
injury
johnny
johnny
and
why is it why is this lawyer bringing
this up
i want to i really want to know what
this lawyer is thinking as he's reading
this like
i wonder what else
he hasn't planned for her throat if it's
not for injury
is it
is he gonna
choke her with water like i wonder what
no sir it's for something oh so i'm like
johnny
johnny what are you
doing johnny
boy
how would you react if your husband sent
that to you like tonight i'ma do
something to your throat that doesn't
include injury what would you
i'm like oh god
or okay not even your husband what if
someone that if you were talking to
someone right now what if they said that
to you right now
like what if in the middle of this you
got that text if i got that oh gosh my
phone be be dry i'm not gonna lie to you
but it
if i got that if i got that text um
have we hooked up before
it's whatever scenario like you are
really feeling this guy and you're like
but we've never like done anything i'd
be weirded out okay if we've done it if
we've done something okay
i'm gonna be honest i
would probably like
not say anything
but i would think it was kind of weird
oh okay okay i'd be like uh but i would
i'm kind of agreeable
so i just feel like oh
yeah that's so
so hot okay
i'm so sexy
okay what about you dad you seem into it
it seems like you'd be you'd be running
no no if it was my husband like the man
i'm married and that's my that's my
homie that's my dude i've been like
which dm must we be lonely
if
this is the best sign you have i don't
know why that's different from husband
to them because it's like if it's your
husband that's that's your man yeah
you're right he's my dude because who
else has he sent that to if we're just
talking yeah who you who else who sent
it to you there are these boys in the
street period period i don't want to be
have you heard you've heard that song uh
a lady in the streets with a freaking
bed i i've heard the phrase i didn't
know it was from a song oh
am i outside uh
what did i miss
there's a song you didn't know it was
song there's a song about me
i don't even know
[Laughter]
no no tell me about this song was it a
bop can i shimmy to it yes
it's an old song
no i don't know no no no um
no angus
yeah by usher i want to ladies
and gentlemen i do
yeah oh i do know that song yeah it's
the is there in the rap part i thought i
thought that the song was called the
lady in the oh
no no i do know the yasa okay i know
that song very well
i do
when i was in high school i made a dance
to that song oh really would you like to
show the people of the day
i don't want to scar everybody
it'll be behind the scenes footage yeah
yeah watch out sign up to our membership
only fans
no we don't i we don't have those just
kids
unless for the right price
what do you want our content i'm kidding
okay let's just we've got custom other
uses for your throat
which do not include injury
sorry could you read that
again we're drinking pretty heavily
were you there the ugly situation with
amber mister
with respect to trying to respect the
court's time and the jury signed that
was not my question my question was
when you would agree
you would agree you would agree that
objection calls for hearsay
let me ask you a different question mr
deb
um let's let him object to another one
had a conversation
with miss hurt
[Music]
yes they have
[Music]
[Music]
i guess
[Music]
how can he huh
how can he he hasn't said anything
how is he able to hear like strike at
his hearsay i don't know what hearsay
means like
should i go yes because i think i would
hear
say
meaning okay
information received from other people
which cannot be substantiated rumor
so how is it hearsay if he heard her say
it yeah and if he's having the
conversation with her but
is it because he received the
information from her
i'm not smart enough for these
conversations yes i don't know because
first of all he hasn't even said
anything so i'm trying to understand
like how can he say hearsay if you're
not even letting him get
any word in to be able to say oh that's
hearsay okay an example of hearsay would
be where person a sees someone climbing
into the window of a house a later tells
b that the person
he saw was c evidence of b
evidence from b of what a told him is
hearsay
wait
yeah i still
wait a later tells b that the person he
saw was c
oh so basically if it's
so if i told you
that
so i saw someone break the law and then
you told gabby
that um
that i told you that someone broke the
law gabby could not testify in court
because that's hearsay
but i don't that doesn't seem applicable
here because he's the one that's having
conversations yeah
but i don't think this lawyer knows what
he's talking about
i don't know
read one definition about
about the law
like he doesn't know what he's talking
about
yes i looked at papers
maybe they're here
i can read it out of
someone's article
not from the man's mouth
okay
what you
what'd you think of that
uh
hold on
where is this coming from um
i don't know how i got talking about
snowden guys give me give me 30
okay that's off
this case is just
very interesting because i know if it
was the other way around this would not
be happening no it wouldn't it would not
be happening and that
it's
frustrating that it is happening
because
he has to
prove his innocence on a
essentially now false
allegation
and
when
when those situations happen it's like
the person isn't thinking about the
other person's life yeah he's down ew
yes he may have money but he still is
losing out on things that
he could be doing and he lost out on a
huge franchise that um
didn't ask him to come back because of
her allegations and
it just well it's it's his livelihood
yeah like even even this stuff i don't i
mean yes i want to make money send super
chats super chat
but um
but like it's about it's like what gives
you life you know like you're playing
basketball or whatever it is that like
gives you you know a sense of purpose in
life but
like she took that away from him and i
think that's meaner than money
i think so too because
you're
it's almost like you're taking a part of
someone's freedom yeah away
by
falsely accusing them
of something
as this
because you know that
you can possibly benefit from it and you
won't have very many people
asking about it because you are a woman
and this is something that
you know she she said that
to him there's like accounts in the
trial where she said no one's going to
believe you because i'm a girl
and then
then why is this why is this trial even
going on if she says stuff like that
like that should be dismissed i'm not if
i was the judge i'd be like oh you said
what okay bet
case dismissed you won mr deb i
stuff like that that shows you that
someone
didn't care about you doesn't care about
you and they were out to
ruin you with a statement like that and
knowing that i'm a lie on you and i know
i'm going to get away with it because
i'm a woman
and then how many men has this happened
to yeah
which is nuts
like it's that's why in a society it's
never when people don't face
accountability [ __ ] happens
like it should have just because she's
born a girl if you i i swear to god i
want to start a movement called hit the
[ __ ] okay
i know i swear to god if she comes at
you with a knife or she hits you hit her
back
i mean self-defense i just feel like
equal rights equal left that's a chess
equal rights equal lapse look at it i
don't i don't go around hitting people
you hit men no no so we would i don't
we would never get hit back no but for
the girls that choose to partake in that
that is your own damn fault
yeah like how do you get to any other
dude if a weaker guy
attacks a bigger guy he gets his ass
wrecked why is it same with the woman
same woman
you know if a weaker woman hits a right
yeah yeah they're going they're going to
scrap but it's like
women can
you can hit a dude and you can express
this that in the third
and physically on a dude but you expect
them to stay calm and stay
poised and just eat them punches like
they
it's like no
because they're human too they're gonna
get upset and get frustrated and then
and then if they leave
then you're like why are you leaving why
are you leaving it's like because they
don't if you don't want to be put up
with abuse put up with abuse they're not
going to want to put up with it either
and then you get upset when they go
cheat on you and find somewhere else
find somebody else oh she said it she
said it and and they get mad but like
they'll go on social media and cry oh he
left me he left me what about
what about when you're an abusing man
what did you forget
did you
did that it's like always girls will
never tell you what they did wrong
and if they do it's always i was trying
to fix him
it's never i need i need all women
don't try to fix nobody
no more
i i'm tired of that i'm trying to fix
him out trying to fix him no
no more
well it puts you like you're the one in
the right yeah oh i didn't do anything
wrong i was just trying to fix them
what'd you do
we all did something
look it
[Music]
except me and my past relationships
these smoothies are fire right
subscribe to pearl's
smoothie company should i should i make
a smoothie channel guys that could be
like our drink of the day
hey there you go okay all right i hope
you enjoyed this little like snippet
video little short one be sure to
subscribe like and comment down below um
any other videos we should react to
whether they're long short funny
anything just comment down below and
have a great day
bye